In previous videos, you could see us dealing with mimosas.
An invasive tree species that is all over our land.
We cut them, because they are very fire risky.
And, we want to open space for native trees to grow.
The whole region burned down in 2017,
so we want to become more fire resilient.
Last season, we cleared a big patch behind Basekamp.
And, in the previous episode,
we transformed it into a living area.
Now, we are going to take out a bigger patch!
This also will help to understand
better how to deal with these trees.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
So, at the moment, it's getting close to summer,
which is hot summer again.
Fire risks are coming.
We want to take down many of these ones,
so the view will change drastically.
There are a few reasons we do this.
So, the first reason is this one.
The distance between the buildings and the mimosa.
This is not allowed, so we will need to
clear a whole radius around the house.
The second reason on why we want to clear out
is that we want to make more space.
For fruit trees and native trees to grow.
Which, we have done already in this area.
And, the third reason is that we create
more space, and more openness.
Which means we have more space to relax,
and some airflow during summer.
So, we are now in the electricity line,
which less than a year ago, it has been cleared.
And, unfortunately, they are already going
back up to two meters high.
As you might know, mimosas are a big topic for us,
and not only for us!
Many people in the region are struggling with this, because..
What do you do with such a flammable,
and a fast growing species on the land?
What to do?
How do you cut it and how do you process it?
We are going to use our land
to experiment several options from this.
Let's have a look from the top!
This is the area we are going to work in.
We decided to divide the batch in two,
and use different approaches to deal with the mimosas.
On this area,
we will debark them with manual tools.
The trees will then die slowly.
It's an experiment to see if this approach makes sense.
Also, for the rest of our land,
and maybe helpful to others with the same problem.
We will also need to clear a smaller area below the electricity lines,
but not likely that we can debark here.
The other side we will fully chop down with chainsaws.
It's a rough, but a more straightforward approach.
It's needed to create a fire security area
around the office before summer comes.
When the risk of fire increases...
The downside is that the trees will resprout soon,
but for the moment, we need to take action fast!
Okay, so, today's the day.
It's very windy, but we are going to start anyway.
We're going to start with the area,
which we're going to strip the bark of the mimosas down.
Let's have a look, if there are some people that join me!
I think with this team, we can make it!
Maybe it's a good moment to introduce two more people
of our team, that you already saw in other updates.
I am Marilia! Hi!
I was happily born and raised in Brazil.
But now, my adventure is here,
on the other side of the ocean.
I came to Europe to study screenwriting.
And, by some mysterious and magical means, I arrived here
As a writer, I'm loving this experience.
It is so different from the days
I spend alone behind my computer.
Also, as a person in search of meaning,
this project and these people have been a beautiful gift!
Hi! I'm Sean!
I'm 37, from the United Kingdom!
I work as a freelance software developer,
and I'm passionate about environmental issues and trance music.
I came to Project Camp to experience living in a community.
And, to work in nature, for learning new skills
completely different to what I do back home.
By just typing away on a keyboard.
I don't really know what the future holds for me...
But, I do know that once the season ends,
I wanna come back to Portugal and look for some land of my own.
And hopefully, some of the new friends I've met here, will come visit me.
So, to start off with...
We're going to walk through the area,
and clear all of the small, thin, and dead mimosas.
There's quite a lot of them.
Clear the area up for us, so that we can work properly.
Then, we'll move to the brambles.
So that we definitely got a proper cleared area.
And then, after that, we will start on stripping the mimosas.
As Sean said, we are taking down the dead mimosas first,
and leave them on the ground.
The principle will be that if they are stay up,
they dry and are more prone to burn
On the ground, they were rotten,
so less fire risk and it helps to build some soil.
So, it's kind of cool to walk into this area together,
and collect all the dry sticks.
The sounds are amazing!
- It is good, huh?
Super satisfying!
I feel powerful!
- Timber!
Look at this baby!
We have to protect them now!
all of them.
- Marilia, what do you have there?
Oh, I forgot the name in English.
- Barbed wire?
What?
- Barbed wire!
Barbed wire.
Barbed wire...
And look, they go down...
It's kind of dangerous.
So, we have to watch out.
Now that we've cleared the small, dead mimosas,
we're going to mark out the area and measure it.
So, we can see how much you've got
to do over the next few days.
Now we know that this side is 25.6 meters.
- How much?
How much?
- 23 meters!
588 meters squared.
- Half a hectare?
Wait, no...
Not even close!
After clearing and measuring, we are placing the dry trunks,
to create water retention lines.
This will tidy up the place,
help them rot and retain water.
Which is good to build the soil over time.
Now, it's time to start stripping the bark of the mimosas.
We also want to know how long it takes to debark this area.
And, what tools are better for this task,
so we can have useful information for research on how to deal with them.
We don't need to take all the bark out.
Just around one and a half meters from
the ground will be enough.
It's kind of cool to see and to hear!
You have your own technique!
- The knife technique!
It's going inside of your glove!
Watch out!
All of the bark.
This one is messy!
Yeah, some of the small ones are hard to get the bark off cleanly.
Especially with this saw...
Well, we also could have a nice conversation?
- No, it's impossible, because everything you say,
we put it in the video, and now I don't feel safe.
Am I annoying you?
Are you happy?
- Very much!
These are the roots in the bark!
That's why we have to take it out, so they die.
We just finished the debarking this big batch of mimosas.
One of the advantage of the debarking
is that the mimosas in theory shouldn't sprout.
Another advantage is that we can keep shade for a while,
and also it kind of looks cool!
But, there are some disadvantages as well.
For example, we have to debark them one by one.
We only can do it in the spring, because in summer,
the bark gets really stuck to the tree and it's quite difficult to take out.
And, they took they take a long time to actually die.
One other aspect is that we are not really sure
if the thin ones should be debarked or not.
We've used a number of tools
for working on them on the mimosas.
I'll start the ones I wouldn't recommend...
The ax.
Sometimes it's helpful, but you don't have enough fine control...
Maybe a bit too big for the job.
The machete.
Definitely too big for the job!
Like, you can maybe use it to cut around,
and get your initial cut in the wood.
But, it just doesn't really work very well...
I've used this most of the time,
but again, I wouldn't really recommend it.
With the sawtooth on the knife,
it kind of is just hard to get behind the bark and peel it.
Things that we've used the most:
All these secateurs!
The advantages are that they've got a relatively thin sharp blade.
So, you can really kind of get behind the bark.
But, as you can see, we've broken them.
Yeah, they're stuck.
We don't even need to put the latch on now.
It's just stuck...
So, ideally, and we did order some of these...
But, it didn't arrive...
It would be a knife, like just a small knife.
This is Allie's knife that we've borrowed.
A thin sharp blade can cut into the bark at the top pretty easily,
and you can get in behind it and peel it off.
So, if you're doing this yourself,
we'd recommend you small, sharp knife.
Okay, the debarking is done.
But, before going to the other side of the patch,
we will clear a small area below the electricity lines here
Ale will explain the approach.
So, we've reached a point right below that power line.
Where the municipality cut all of their mimosas last year,
to keep it away from the power itself.
And, you can see now, in one year,
how much they have grown!
It makes it a bit harder for us, because there's a lot of dead wood
and stuff in the bottom, but also a lot of new growth...
What a mess!
- What a mess...
Tricky situation!
So, here you can see what happens
when you only cut the mimosas.
They just keep resprouting all over the place.
We will have to work on it again next year,
and probably in more seasons...
I would like to see how long do they take today,
if we keep cutting them over and over.
We're now almost finished on the half of the mimosa patch,
that we we're debarking.
We've got one job left there.
We need to go and find of the little oaks and other native species.
We've covered them with buckets to stop them from getting damaged,
and build them some proper triangles.
Happy to be saving oaks?
- Yeah!
Okay, so, the debarking area is finished!
It took us around 15 hours,
with the average of a team of five people.
We debarked 500 trees!
A lot!
But, this is not the only area
that we are taking on in this mimosa patch.
We have another site, but we're going to take it
a bit different with a bit more power.
With the same team!
Okay, we're now in the second half of the big mimosa patch,
with still much mimosa to go.
This is also the area where the ruin is.
Where we have the office,
which is where we need to clear all around.
Again, we are starting we're making some space to work properly.
Brushcutting, breaking and putting down all the dry sticks...
And, taking out the brambles,
so they don't pinch in the butt...
Woah! This is huge, Julie!
We found the little lovely friend: the barbed wire...
Always with us...
You never know where you might find it...
Right now, we are moving some dead mimosas,
taking out some brambles...
To make a safe area to work,
because it was kind of messy.
Now, it's beautiful!
Hey, guys?
We already cleaned the whole thing.
It's a nice area to work.
Now, we can tear out the mimosas!
Okay, so, we only cut a couple of square meters,
and we still have a lot to go...
But, we already have huge piles of green matter,
that we don't know what to do with.
This is always a bit of a big problem...
But today, we're going to use one new shredder!
The shredder is cool for us,
because the green matter stays on the land.
It helps to protect and build the soil.
But, we can only shred the green tops
and the thin trunks.
For the bigger ones, we will need to find a different solution.
So, we finished with the flat, easy part.
It's now time to go into the steep and more challenging part
to start cutting the mimosas.
Okay, we realized during working on this steep part:
''It is better if we started down at the office.''
It's very hard and annoying,
to take the trees out from the top.
But, if we start from the bottom,
we can dig them out easier.
I was using all my body weight to do it!
So, as you can see, we got a lot of mimosas!
Now, they are everywhere!
You cannot work, you cannot see the stairs...
So, now, it's time to process them,
and make this place look cleaner.
- Processing party...
Processing party!
So, we finished most of the mimosa cutting.
Now, the last step is just cutting the last tree,
and then make everything a bit nicer.
We have some brambles that we still have to move...
This pile of dead wood that we also
have to spread and make nicer.
Also, these trees are in the way of the office too much.
So, we are going to cut them, and make a nice path.
Now, the last tree!
All the chopping is done!
We have a lot of green matter to get rid of.
Luckily, we have some help from our neighbor,
who will take care of all the trunks.
It would be better if we could keep them on the land.
But, for the moment, we prefer to take them away,
and reduce the fire risk.
As you might see, we are not used
to seeing such a big machinery over here.
Television!
The camera adds pounds, doesn't it?
The camera adds extra pounds here,
which is obviously beneficial...
- A lot!
Yeah, I thought it might!
- But, only to your biceps...
With all of the wood chips, that we got from the tops of the trees...
We are going to use them to spread around the land,
that we just cleared to protect the soil.
And also, to make the parts around the kitchen a little bit nicer.
So, as you can see, the piles are gone!
From the surroundings, the area and the paths!
And now, the job is finally finished!
Looks nice!
Fluffy!
I wish I was a fungus to live down here!
So, we've finished the experiment
with this little part of mimosa on our land.
By this section here, where we debarked it.
And, this section here, where we got busy with the chainsaw.
But, there's still loads more of mimosas on the land,
so we just want to see which approach works best.
We're now in the debarked area.
It looks quite cool, although,
maybe not so dramatic from the top, but...
You can see that we're already starting
to see some changes here.
The debarked area is changing color.
You've got some resin coming out of the wood.
It's going to be an experiment.
Takes a couple of years, and we're looking forward
to see how that turns out.
So, we're now in the section,
that we took out with the chainsaw.
And yes, from down here, it does look ugly with all of the stumps...
We're going to do extra work here.
We're going to plant some native species,
put down woodchips, improve the soil...
But, the reason we did it like this,
it's because we had to do it quickly.
The fire season is almost here,
and the office was very close to all the trees!
So, we needed to protect the office.
We're dealing with the woods in three different ways.
The tops.
We'll use those for wood chips.
You can see this pile here is turning brown.
We've already one big batch of wood chips!
Someone will come with the shredder,
to help us with these again.
And, the reason for that is that we
will use the woodchips to moisten the soil.
Along the water lines is where we put all the dead wood.
That will help retain the water, when it rains.
And, as they break down again, it will moisten the soil.
The third thing is the big trunks.
The neighbor came with the truck,
and helped pick up load off of those.
But, we've got more!
And again, the neighbors are ever so helpful,
and they are going to come and take the rest.
You may be wondering why I've cut down all these trees.
This is the reason!
The mimosa is a pioneer species,
but it's also an invasive species...
So, after the fire, they grow back really quickly
and they crowd out all of the native species, like the oak.
The native species are part of the ecosystem,
and they're also more fire resistant.
So, we're going to promote the growth
of all of the little oaks
And other native species or fruit trees,
and things that we found, so they can grow.
With enough light and space, and hopefully we'll have a forest
of all native species at some point in the future.
So, our experiments here are done!
And, we're hoping that that going to help inform how we do have all of the mimosas on the land.
This is only a small patch!
And, not only for ourselves!
We hope this research will help
other local people and people in the surrounding areas
To also help them deal with mimosas in the most efficient, quickest way,
as it's an invasive species in this region.
But, for now, we're done
and we have this wonderful view!
In the next episode,
we will continue working on the storage container.
This time, it's making the interior of the storage.
If you like what we do, you can support us on Patreon!
You can watch the next episode without ads!
If not, you can subscribe,
and help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching,
and see you in the next episode!